hello and welcome to video playing the
national master rainmaker that all have
zapped right yep Olaf sub um okay that
looks like hmm yeah neither sick sister
it's the best move probably that other
symmetrical Greenfeld I'm going with
this variation here which is objectively
speaking not as good but it has um yeah
it's a little bit more confrontational
black tries to get some pressure on the
form you will be able to take then that
is quite serious on deform very often
white players now choose to capture on
d5 or they play III I think this is also
seen quite frequently the best thing
about this set white players usually
have to play chess from yon and cannot
play a long theoretical line that is
slightly more comfortable for the first
player so okay he decides to take my
knight on c6 is slightly question
replaced but at least now and this now
I've got the bishop open on c8 yeah
night b5 it's really easy milles it's
definitely a move yeah I don't want to
go a six this is a bit that we can
smooth out any area necessity mm-hmm
don't like it
he has Queen d2 now for possibly bishop
age six but I have night f5 mmm yeah
9595 was the move I could have played
maybe also instead up it should be six
should have thought about this a little
bit a little bit more carefully maybe
yeah shooting for g5 and yeah this
definitely to the kind of position that
I wanted to have something that is a
little bit more a little bit more
unconventional i'm not sure if it is
good though mmm night each fri am a king
hmm now you can take that and maybe take
on d5 this is not yeah that's not what I
wanted maybe I'd rather go here for ya
attack that pawn and see I can go g5 as
well g5 and f5 it's an interesting way
of playing
let's not do this you might take on this
exam and then f5 looks a yeah more than
stupid
yeah I don't think that white like to
take on f5 but what is this move I have
a couple of ideas also 94 94 95 is a is
a possibility yeah but here I can
definitely take and play Knight c4 and
they have f4 f4 possibly f3 hmm okay I'm
taking this lets you for is a key thing
I also have night efore what about 94 he
will have to take it otherwise I'd take
on three three and then I take with the
f pawn that looks like a strategically
very good position so let's do that this
looks good I've got a strong central
presence with the pawns and potentially
I might even just whitney five twin 67
rook e8 Bishop c8 and it's gone
something like that maybe Queen to e7
rather yeah this is what I thought that
would probably happen but the resulting
position is also comfortable for black I
just have the better structure here to
see seven or eight seven and then can go
e seven
yeah this one hmm that's something that
I saw a tete tete too late it's not it's
not a problem but now anyway if Quincy
five as well and try to take you five if
I was also hanging so I mean unprotected
so this is an additional thing look the
eight maybe
yeah rook to e8 Queen f2 I guess can
also check here try to go yeah let's do
that try to take it only five between f2
I think I don't mind okay so um Bishop
b5 is there a problem with the move I
don't see it at the moment so I'm taking
it
yes so I'm one that pawn and that's nice
and we like the cleaning the game or
ever it's not that easy I'm not so happy
with this hmm I should have done that
differently going for I can just take it
I don't have a have a clear follower I
thought the check but it's not a big
deal and Bishop c4 was my idea but he
probably can just play rugby one yeah
Jack hmm there any way to give you this
one if he leaves the first rank I have
to check on tivo
Ruby of seven check is no I can't just
take through hoops hey I can just take
the route i was running right why is
this possible in fact it isn't possible
check check check check check okay to be
somewhat quick but it seems possible
check me okay yeah but got somewhat
close huh yeah so we had this somewhat
unconventional opening but it did
exactly what it's supposed to do get to
a yeah somewhat uncommon position and
then you can sometimes outplay the
opponent yeah yeah I like my position I
already do the engine wants to go g5
this is this it's probably better after
this I think my position is very very
decent taking g 4 and so on it looks
like a good position and i think after
that i'm quite happy he has to play what
we saw in the game some f porn but now
those pawns are simply a weakness and in
the game Jen chieh one of them dropped
so
it's probably ways to allocate Quincy
for the strong move for that I didn't
see at all only this that is a Texas was
check that's very nice well and it's
even better yeah I've got the pawn but
nothing special young until I still
having a little something with this
initiative but Jay the of course helped
a lot that he played apt to have one a
move that took me a moment to realize
that I can just take it NTM yeah I'm
just a just a hookup and that opening
line is quite interesting against some
93g 3c four setups it's not yeah it's
not super reliable but as we have seen
it is definitely possible to play
together somewhat unconventional game
yeah thanks for watching